[Music]
hello a few months ago i moved house and
i'm lucky enough to have a whole room
for my computer
and to record in and stuff and i know a
few of you are really interested in
seeing what my studio looks like so i
thought i'd show you around today so
follow me
i'll pick you out
here's my bookshelf
it's full of
books and plants
and
got some amiibos
the plants look very pretty in the
bookcase but unfortunately they don't
get much light so usually i have to take
the plants
during the day
over to my window seat follow me and
i'll take you to the window seat
[Music]
this is the window seat this is where i
wake up in the morning and i play animal
crossing
it's really nice because you can see
squirrels outside on the trees
because the old lady downstairs leaves
food out for the squirrels and it makes
them very fat but they stick around
which is really nice for me
[Laughter]
here is something that i painted
it's a birdhouse but i don't have a
garden so it lives here
and it's got a junji ito spiral on the
inside so if birds do decide to live
here they'll get very dizzy
but i thought it's quite cool
it's fall out on the outside and junji
ito on the inside
these are done by a talented onion
these are done by amy
here we have a witch 3 map
[Music]
mirror
and over here
is my writing desk
this is where i go
if i want to write because i'm trying to
write a short story but it's very
difficult
i'm a thousand words in
hopefully 2 000 by the end of this month
but i like to bite here because
i don't know there's something nice
about being
not at the your usual workspace
and uh i feel like there's less
distractions on this part of the desk so
i can just wheel my chair
over to here and just
write
with the
the light and stuff
here is my cork board
it has all my pictures of my friends
that i haven't seen in a long time so
it makes me really
nostalgic when i look at the pictures
and also
i'm really bad at remembering important
words and being a designer that's not a
great trait because i need to
communicate with other people a lot of
the time so i wrote down all the
important designer words
and wrote them here
if you'd like me to do a video
sharing with you important designer
words
and
their meanings
then let me know and i can share it with
you because i needed it
words like affordances
signifiers
constraint
perceived affordances
different than affordances
then uh yeah we can do a whole video on
design words and communication
uh very important stuff right so here
is foam
things that are supposed to stop me
being loud
but i don't think they work
i just got them because every other
youtuber has them
but i don't think they work but i put
them back here anyway
it was a kerfuffle because i'm renting
this place and they fell off the wall so
i had to put them on cardboard and they
fell off the cardboard so
sometimes they still fall down but
they're up at the moment and that's what
counts
um
this is the computer
this is what i was saving up for years
those of you who have been following me
for years know that i was waiting for a
computer for many years
and it's finally here
we got two monitors
we got
some fancy streaming lights
oh
i have
a webcam here but actually funny thing i
don't use this webcam
uh this is like a lodgy
c390 i think
could be wrong i'll double check um but
i actually prefer the image quality from
my phone so i have two phones that i use
my actual phone
and
this phone which actually i just use for
recording
songs and stuff and as a webcam so it's
usually always up here
so that's my phone this is my computer
this is the computer
tower
beautiful
this is my switch
and i guess that's about it
we've got oh yeah we have um my guitar
it looks very nice in its stand
whenever i'm in a meeting
people see it
behind me and usually people comment on
how beautiful she is
because she is
and then
we have my ukulele
here
she doesn't get stand
and uh i usually play
play the guitar
sitting here on my little window seat
which is nice
it's very uh relaxing
chill
um
this is my tech woman 100 award
which is cool
this is a book
that i love
it's about things that never were look
come here it tells you old
mythol mythological tales and talks
about witchcraft and
different
religions and gods and
mythological creatures
it's super cool
yeah
i think that's about it
okay
well that was my studio
i hope you enjoyed it
hi everyone so seeing as we've now had
the studio tour i thought we would also
do a q a because it's been a little
while since we've just sat down and
chatted together
so let's do this
thank you so much to everyone who asked
me questions i got way more than i even
imagined but unfortunately i can only
answer one at a time
i have also sectioned these questions
off in two different categories so you
can skip to the point in the video that
you'd like to hear the answers
the categories are game dev questions
creative product questions
and then personal questions
and we're going to begin with patreon
questions as always patreons come first
first question is from michael cass and
they ask what does a typical day in your
life look like what is your schedule we
want to see your day
and
i could do a day in the life video if
you want me to i honestly don't do many
vlogs or anything like that anymore
because i don't do much i feel like i
just stay in my room and
don't do much but if you'd like to see
it do let me know in the comments below
if 196 asked what is your favorite part
of the creative process and this is
quite a difficult question because the
creative process
just has massive highs and massive lows
throughout the whole entire thing but i
think my favorite part is probably the
the part the very beginning where you're
coming up with ideas you're getting
inspiration you're researching you get
kind of obsessive over the idea and
you're just super super excited about it
that is always really really fun and
then you've just got to kind of
truck through all of the
hard work that comes after that but
hopefully
it's worthwhile at the end
vixelite says have you ever thought of
doing a meet and greet at an event like
insomnia
and honestly no because i thought that
nobody would come
and i'd be like hey i'm here and we
stood around just like
but if you would come and you would like
me to do something like that then let me
know by giving a like on this video or
letting me know in the comments down
below and i'll see what i can do
gaming with malachi asks what webcam do
you use and as you saw in the studio
tour i actually use my second phone
which is a samsung note 9 which was
actually gifted to me by mantas who is
also a patreon so thank you so much
mantas it's my webcam and it's honestly
the the best quality that i could hope
for i use an app called droid cam and
you can get that on your pc and on your
phone and then i just connect them
together via usb and it works perfectly
and talky of mantas mantas or also known
as it's your boy
asks me what makes you happy and are you
really happy now and that's a really
really deep question that i have taken a
lot of
thought to answer
so i need to read it
so i'm actually coming to terms recently
with the fact that
what makes you happy changes and that's
okay so what might have made me happy a
year ago might not be what makes me
happy now and that's not something wrong
with me that's just a part of
of growing up uh and i think as i'm
getting older i'm realizing that the
things that truly do make me happy are
the really small things in life and just
being able to
get outside be in nature experience
things and obviously be around people
who love me for who i am and i don't
have to be anyone but myself you know my
my friends my family just people
who i feel so close and comfortable with
it's actually really difficult to find
people like that and when you do have
them you really should enjoy their
company because
that's probably
one of the happiest times that you will
feel
and as for am i happy now um
obviously i have my days where i'm very
happy in my days when i'm very low
but i am working towards
my own happiness and bettering myself
and looking after myself more by going
to therapy
thinking about
self-care putting self-care stuff in my
to-do lists
so
i think
generally
yes but there's definitely more work
that i could do and i'm taking the steps
to get it done
i probably should also add here i'm not
gonna lie i have been struggling with
anxieties after lockdown and that's one
of the reasons why i've gone to therapy
and it hasn't
it hasn't been the same since before
coverage i'm sure everyone probably has
this feeling where they just there's a
feeling that they can't really describe
it's it's not very nice and they've got
to figure it out uh after kobit and i
would say if you're struggling like me
do phony doctor go to therapy if talking
about it really does help or it helps me
at least
now we're moving on to the game dev
question and this question is from r
croft's 2000.
just like the nimbus 2000 or something
um
okay
they asked me what are my specs and i'm
just going to get jacob the lovely
editor to please write them on screen
now i've given you them in a note so you
can write them here i don't know them
off by heart because i'm not really a
hardware person so when i came to
getting my pc i actually just asked my
friends who are really techy people and
they helped me a lot and then i paid for
it and then i got it
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah okay
josu has asked me if there's anything
that's more important to have in your
studio because they they're trying to
build up their own studio space but they
don't have too much money and i would
just say
obviously
your pc comes first all your equipment
that you're actually going to be doing
work on that has to come first with the
money that you're spending um but if
you've already got that sorted you're
just looking for the space think about
you and what makes you work better
everyone's different
i like to be like i said around nature
so hence why i do have plants in here
and it's not an abundance but it's
enough to make me feel happy i like to
look outside so therefore i made sure
that my desk was near a window but not
so close that it's going to get loads of
light glare or anything like that on the
screens
i like to take breaks and play my guitar
so i wanted to make sure i had a nice
little guitar stand
and i do like to look at pretty things
so having a little bookcase it's nice
for me to look at all my books and put
some candles i really like so many
candles so how do you work what makes
you get in the zone what makes you feel
happy
do you like minimalistic spaces do you
like big open spaces if so that's great
that's actually really cheap you don't
have to buy much for your room but are
you like me do you like nature do you
want a plant to look after do you play
music do you read books um is there
visual inspirations that you have that
maybe you want to put all over the walls
that's kind of what i would say you
should think about
carlos underscore 7x asked me what's the
first game that you played and what game
got you into game development or maybe
made you want to be a game developer um
so first game i honestly can't remember
my mom tells me that i've been playing
games ever since i was like a toddler
and they had a pc at the end of their
bed so i would sit at the end of that by
playing the pc so i guess maybe it was
like snake or something don't know
um
i think the games that that made me
interested in game development would be
games like beyond good and evil
gregory's horror show
the harry potter games one two three
games that really got me
um
into a new world and made me really
appreciate that form of art
but i think also games that super
inspired me were also from miniclip and
just little indie games that people have
made on their own like everyday the same
or immortal they're extremely small
games and like i say they're just made
by probably one person and put on
miniclip.com which for those who are
young um
it was like a website where you would
just play free flash games it was
kind of old now um but yeah it was super
super inspiring because these games were
very short but they made you think about
life they made you question things and
made you come away
actually questioning things about
yourself and i did write an article
about this actually a long time ago so
uh if i find it i'll put it in the
description down below
sankit patil asks what was your
inspiration to become a game dev and
honestly it's always just been to tell
stories my whole goal in my life has
been to tell stories when i was a kid i
was just writing stories all the time
so yeah tell stories basically
leon greta and eric ruiz both asked me
about a possible next
game
project
and um short answer is i aim to make
another game in the future
long answer is
um
i
it's currently not viable for me to make
a video game at the moment with my
full-time job there's simply not enough
time in the day
especially when i'm doing live streams
and other videos like this one
um
i am currently looking into ways that i
can
maybe focus on a bigger project in the
future that would mean dropping some
things which is extremely scary um but i
am working working towards figuring out
what i want and how to do it because i'm
not naturally business-minded i don't
know how to make money from the things
that i make um so it is extremely it's a
very scary thought for me to to not have
a full-time job because i'm like i say
i'm not business-minded um but hopefully
hopefully one day
um i can be in the
in a financial position and also in a
confident position like confident in
myself enough to take the step to
to create something
again that i'm extremely proud of and
something a bit more finished
that hopefully you can enjoy
that's also why i'm making loads of game
dev music videos and stuff like that
because i'm still learning i'm learning
loads of techniques so hopefully i can
put them to good use one day in the
future but thank you for asking i i
still baffled by the amount of people
that want me to make more video games
and you know really still enjoy
perfection and
tell me nice things about it all the
time so thank you thank you so much it
means a lot
now on to creative project questions and
the first one is from
craig bagley who says
what motivates you
uh good question i don't know
it seems to be kind of like an innate
need
to
um
create things that express myself and
that hopefully can connect with others i
mean maybe it's the whole finding your
tribe thing and
hopefully i can put something out there
that makes a positive impact on someone
but also
affirms my own view on the world and my
own emotions and feelings um
whatever it is it's a very addictive
feeling and uh it definitely is highly
motivating so
hopefully that somewhat answers your
question
moo master 101 says how do you organize
yourself to do all the different types
of things that you want to do so game
dev music videos
all of the things and i say this is a
very very good question and as i kind of
touched on earlier i do get overwhelmed
by it and i am
working through
uh some thoughts and frustrations that i
have right now over
me really wanting to work on just one
big project versus all these tiny ones
um but that's something that i'm working
on
in my head and with my therapist but
what i do
to do all of this because
i always think i'm not doing enough and
i'm like i'm not outputting very much
but whenever i get questions like this
i'm like oh okay maybe it does look like
i'm managing to pull it off somehow um
but what i do to try to pull it off is i
do a to-do list uh try and do it every
day don't
you know get an audit myself if i don't
manage to do it every day that's fine
but what i do do is i do it every month
um
what i do every month is put to-do list
of what i want to achieve that month and
then i color code it so i have different
colors for game dev youtube music
writing and personal so self-care stuff
like this stuff that's going to make me
happy
and i tried to
make each to-do at least one of the
different categories so that i'm going
to do something
to build upon those different skills and
also to make me happy and i try not to
do
any more than five to-do's so it might
be like start on a writing no
start on a music video
write a thousand more words in your book
um you know
play a new video game
things like that and then i can reflect
on them after the month and see how i've
done
now i'm not gonna lie i never do them
all i never complete them all i haven't
figured that out yet
but i've always ticked off at least like
two or three of them which is really
good and uh also it helps me to manage
my google calendar i put everything in
my google calendar if i know what i'm
supposed to achieve for that month i do
try and make a sort of structure for
myself but having a full-time job does
make it hard sometimes you just get
really tired after work and you you
don't want to do what your calendar is
telling you to do and that's also okay
but
if you've got it there then you know
what you're supposed to do and you can
just maybe push it back to tomorrow or
something um
so yeah
to-do lists calendars tasks deadlines
but soft deadlines be
be good to yourself
devoncho2 says how do you deal with work
and stress and still look beautiful
thank you um
but a i do not look like this all the
time i literally only put makeup on for
like live streams uh and on the weekend
but
i guess i i do have a self-care routine
on a friday where i will put my coconut
oil in my hair do a face mask and all
that kind of stuff
um
but yeah i definitely don't look like a
goddess all of the time and uh
especially when i am overwhelmed and
stressed
geez you have not seen me like that so
so yeah don't get the wrong impression
it's literally impossible but it's fine
bergy asked what are your greatest
strengths
well what is your greatest strength and
what is your greatest weakness
and um
i'd like to say that my greatest
strength is
overthinking but to the point where
i'm quite good at
threading multiple ideas or inspirations
to make one cohesive piece of art
i think that comes from a mixture of
like curiosity a little bit of obsession
absolutely love research and writing
and yeah just overthinking just
constantly questioning and figuring out
stuff and
i do like to think that yeah that's a
strength like i can piece things
together and i can come up with
something cohesive most of the time
weakness is definitely my confidence um
it has held me back and it does hold me
back so as i said before that's what i'm
working on i absolutely love creating
and working i love it but as soon as
someone starts to ask me about it i
start to doubt myself and i don't like
talking about it even
you know just people who ask me very
very sweet questions but no ill
intentions behind it i just suddenly
think oh my gosh i have nothing to say i
don't know what to say
i just freeze up because the confidence
isn't there and it holds me back from
forming relationships that would help me
in a work sense and um
yeah get getting further in my career i
guess like that need to work on that and
i am working on that so don't you worry
rhys king asks do you have an
inspiration board or any tips to get
inspired
and no i don't have an inspiration board
i'm quite lucky because i have so many
ideas
it's just a massive backlog of ideas and
i never seem to like have to worry about
that side of things um
and what i do is whenever i do have an
idea whether that be from a dream or
a simple thought or maybe i watched a
film and i wished it had a different
ending i write it down whether that be
in my journal in google keep or even in
the discord group that a lot of you are
in i actually have a private section
that's just for me that's all of my
video ideas game ideas music ideas
uh yeah so that's right under your noses
and you didn't even know that it existed
but i think just writing down every
single idea even if it's just the
tiniest drop of an idea and it just is
not cohesive or anything at all write it
down because you never know when you
might have a larger idea and then
suddenly that idea fits in with that and
then you have a fully volley made piece
um
so yeah that's definitely that advice uh
oh and tips to come up with ideas i
guess it would just be
to just have fun with it and roll with
your feelings uh that's how i do it
anyway uh just ask questions be curious
what inspires you like when you watch a
piece of media or whatever what hits you
hardest like what stays with you after
you've left
that
theater experience or whatever it is
and uh what do you feel really strongly
about
and from that can you create a piece
from that can you replicate that emotion
that feeling that
stance that you have about an experience
or a situation can you replicate that in
a creative form or if not is there
something that you can do
to try and
replicate that through the audience
instead um
i'm not sure if that makes any sense but
when i'm whenever i'm trying to
especially with songs whenever i'm
trying to write a song it's an emotion
that i feel and it's usually something
i'm trying to work through in the moment
creativity really helps with that
creative projects helps you understand
your own feelings
so honestly i just think start with your
feelings
and then let it roll from there don't be
scared just do it
and that's the most raw pieces of art as
well um i'm sure people can relate to
those pieces so
good luck
all right this one is very important
listen very carefully rage in the cage
asked is there any tips that you have to
shake off bad mood or exhaustion when
you are in the middle of a project or
anything like that
i've had a lot of bad advice when it
comes to this topic that does trigger me
um
i've heard people just say you know just
just keep working just go for it like
force yourself to do it and you can you
can nail it yeah
but
no i i do think it's a good idea if you
feel up to it to start working for like
maybe half an hour and just see
if it kick-starts you out of your funky
mood and if you're working and you feel
worse or you feel the same
after about half an hour or an hour
stopped
stopped just stopped
you are not going to feel better working
is not going to make you feel better
we are all different people some people
can just work every single day and they
don't need
rest or anything i mean
i'm thinking they're lying but they say
they don't so sure they they don't but
a lot of us myself included do need to
rest up and to do self-care and to just
you know be away from the projects that
we're working on sometimes to actually
experience life beyond the computer
screen
um it's something that i definitely
still struggle with because there's only
a limited amount of time in the day
especially when you have a full-time job
as well and you want to make the most
out of that time but also you want to
live your life you want to be happy you
want to
be around your friends and your family
you want to see the sun rise in the
morning you know you want to
look at the birds flying outside your
window and
you can't do that when you
focus on your projects all the time so
it's really hard to find that balance
but usually if i'm in a really bad mood
and really bad place and i'm not getting
knocked out of it when i'm starting to
do work it's probably because i need
that rest and maybe that's what you go
through when you feel like that's who
you need that rest and it's extremely
difficult but try not to feel guilty for
letting yourself have that rest it's
actually more productive to let yourself
have a day of rest a day of enjoying
things a day of being outside being
around people that you love
doing whatever it is you have to do to
recover and then you can come back the
next day and feel so much more
productive i i promise you if you force
yourself to work and you don't get out
that funk and you just try to ignore the
feeling that's still there you're just
going to work yourself into a really bad
burnout and you won't want to look at
that project again let alone finish it
so that's just not productive at all and
if you
feel that this this feeling persists or
it keeps coming back very often
i would say if you're a female
look at your your cycle of the month um
yeah so you can develop depression
around a pms time um
and also yeah i would say just phone
your doctor
you don't just need to phone them for
medication although don't look down on
medication medication can definitely
help
but also the doctors can talk to you
about about therapy about other things
that that might help you and if you
think you you can't afford therapy your
doctor will be able to tell you if if
there is a cheaper option for you in
your area um so yeah then the doctor if
you feel like it's it's becoming a
severe problem and you you can't work or
you can't enjoy your work anymore
because that's not good look after
yourself please
you you and your happiness is number one
priority
danger mouse 2 asks are you doing a next
music project and yes i'm working on one
right now it's another unreal engine um
music video that the song's already done
so hopefully it'll come out maybe
sometime next month or something very
excited for that
um and i am working on the second ep
with jamie it's trucking along very
slowly i need to get back to the studio
now but life keeps getting in the way
but it is in the works so yes
okay now we're into the personal
questions and we're starting with jan
dio who asks what was your initial plan
for your youtube channel and how much
has it changed since uh it's quite
interesting because i looked back at my
first video
it turns out i didn't know what i wanted
to do back then i wanted to make a
youtube channel just sharing what i was
really interested in and being creative
online and look i haven't changed isn't
that interesting i still do basically
the same thing but all that has changed
is that the content has refined a bit
it's got a a lot more professional if i
do say so myself very much like myself
but yeah this channel is basically just
a reflection of my scattered brain and i
think it always has been but
yes it's it's definitely showing that my
skills have improved so um yeah it's
nice
sahara ed i'm so i'm so sorry if i'm
bittering anybody's names by the way
really sorry um but you asked how many
instruments do i have and which one is
my favorite and i have an
electro-acoustic uh guitar it was a part
of guitar so it's like a little bit
smaller because i'm a little bit smaller
so it's the perfect size for me and a
ukulele as well which is very very very
small um
and i love them both i mean my ukulele
is my first instrument that i i learned
to play but i gotta say i i just love
the guitar i i love the guitar and
everyone who sees it just tells me how
beautiful she is and i'm like i know
i love her
oh anyway
princess lettuce asks do you want pets
and i say hell yeah definitely want pets
i probably won't get them until i'm able
to afford a house though because rented
places don't allow you to have pets most
of the time which is sad
mateo asks dogs or cats and
i like both but i'm gonna say cats
because i grew up with cats and i had a
very fond relationship with all of my
cats
and katie casey says do you have any
fashion inspiration to share um or what
is my fashion inspiration so
i don't know where i get fashion
inspiration from i guess a bit of
everywhere i mean definitely some tv
shows like the queen's gambit oh great
um but i think what i've learned because
i used to before all of this i used to
work in retail in um in fashion retail
uh next new look ugh they were horrible
places to work but i worked in caramel
as well actually i actually really
enjoyed working there and i learned a
lot about silhouettes and um
especially if you're so i've learnt for
me you'll have to learn what silhouette
works best for you because everybody's
shape is different um but for me because
i'm i'm a petite girl very tall no no
not i'm the opposite i am very short um
i
wear
like
high-waisted
trousers straight cuts i swear a lot of
skinnies but now i'm learning that
actually straight cuts or even wide cuts
actually make my legs look longer
therefore make me look taller which is
good for me
um
and then if you look at like tops with
maybe sleeves like this so if i if i'm
wearing like an outfit it'll like go
[Music]
anyway that's the kind of silhouette
you're going for
where everyone wants the hourglass
so it's all about looking at your own
body and seeing what silhouette works
for you also colors so what color is
your hair what color is your skin i
don't wear much pale clothing because i
would look like i was naked or something
so
i wear a lot of like dark clothes and
autumnal colors because of my hair color
and also my eye color um so yeah look at
the color palette see what colors go
with your your hair your eyes um and
that's probably the colors that
will
be nice on you when you wear them
tips
okay
and that is the end of the q a that was
a long q a i have very red cheeks i'm
very hot now
but it was really nice just reflecting
and answering some of your questions
i'm very flattered that i got so many
questions so thank you very much i hope
you enjoyed this video do let me know in
the comments below if there is any topic
that you
really really really would like to hear
more about i definitely got some music
videos on the way and more game dev
related content so i will see you in the
next video or live stream on thursdays
at 8 30 pm bst
and have a lovely see your evening
bye
you